We have a very,
very special guest with us here today.
Her name is Kristin Neff and we have
a very interesting topic for today.
So thank you so much for being here.
You're welcome.
Let me just tell you,
I briefly
about,
um,
how I got involved with self compassion
and how it got to the point where it is
now, where it's really my life's work. Um,
it actually all started
not too far from here.
I was going to graduate
school at UC Berkeley.
I'm getting my phd and
basically my life was a mess.
I had just gotten out of a divorce.
It was very messy.
I was feeling a lot of shame.
Um, I was under a lot of stress,
not so much about what I get my phd,
but what's it going to get
a job after getting my phd?
That was a big stressor for
me. Um, and so, you know,
I was in Berkeley and I
had heard about meditation.
I had heard that meditation was good
for stress and there was literally,
I'm a meditation group just
down the block from me.
So I went to this meditation group.
Um, and really to my surprise,
the woman leaving the group at talked
about the importance of self compassion,
about how we had this ability
to be kind, supportive, caring,
tour ourselves. Um, when times
were difficult. Uh, and it was,
it was like exactly the message I
needed to hear in that moment. Um,
believe it or not,
I started changing the way we laid
it to myself instead of judge you,
myself and Jamie myself.
I started to try to be that
good kind support a friend. Um,
and it made a huge difference
almost immediately. Uh,
and then luckily I did get a job.
I got a job at ut Austin where I am now
and then I decided I wanted to research
self compassion because I thought
it offered a lot of benefits. Um,
that self esteem didn't it?
I actually did two years of post doctoral
study with the self esteem we suture.
And while it was while I was working
with her, I realized self esteem,
although it was good for mental health
is pretty problematic. For instance, um,
the half high self esteem,
we have to be special and above average,
like everyone has to be at the same time,
special and above average,
which is basically a logical and
possibility, right? So, um, we, we,
we get involved with all these ego
games trying to raise their self esteem,
suddenly putting other people
down or getting ego defensive. Um,
the other problem with self esteem
was it's really contingent, right?
Self esteem is there for you
and things are going well,
but what happens when you fail
your self esteem, dessert shoe.
So as learning all this,
my postdoc and I was practicing self
compassion and seeing really what a stable
refuge self compassion was
in terms of self worth.
So when I got to ut Austin, um, I decided
I wanted to connect research on that.
So the way I,
I define self compassion is I define
it as having three main components,
right? This is, I'm
kindness toward oneself. Um,
a recognition of common
humanity and mindfulness.
A lot of people have
talked about mindfulness.
A mindfulness is actually embedded in the
construct of self compassion the way I
see it. So let me take you through each
of these a little bit more closely.
So the ideas was self compassion.
Again,
we treat ourselves with the same kindness,
care and concern that we showed a good
friend as opposed to harsh self judgment.
You know the Bible says do unto others
as you would have them do unto you.
Good idea,
but really not such a good idea to do
on the others as you do unto yourself.
Because most of us are
shockingly crew author ourselves.
We say things to ourselves kind
of mean, harsh, cruel shaming,
things that we wouldn't say to
anyone we cared about that. In fact,
you probably wouldn't even say to
someone we didn't like very much, right?
If you actually start to tune
into your internal dialogue,
most people are surprised by how
hard they are with themselves.
So the ideas with self compassion,
we start changing the
way we talk to ourselves.
We start changing the way we relate to
ourselves. We didn't be kind, caring,
patient, understanding the way you are
with a friend as opposed to inpatient,
cold and cruel, right? So self kindness.
It involves first of all,
soothing and comforting ourselves in
times of struggle the way you might with a
friend who was upset or a loved one.
It also involves supporting and
protecting ourselves, right?
So self compassion. It's not just
like touchy feely, more fuzzies.
Self compassion can actually be
quite fierce. They can say, listen,
I need to stand up for myself.
I need to protect myself.
I need to draw boundaries.
Sometimes that's really part of being
a good friend who yourself is also
standing up for yourself when you need
it the most. Okay, so self compassion.
Basically the sum up,
what compassion is,
I'm technically compassion is defined
as concern with the alleviation of
suffering and mass.
The thing with self compassion as well,
it means we are actively concerned
with their own suffering and we say,
what do I need in the moment?
And then we try to give
ourselves what we need to leave.
He ate her suffering by the way,
just like a little footnote,
when I use the word suffering,
I just mean any sort of emotional pain.
So when people hear the word suffering,
they think that Jesus dying on the cross.
That's not the way I'm using it. So
it, that's a connotation for you.
Just recognize when I
use the word suffering,
I just mean any moment of emotional pain,
which from my point of view is worthy
of a compassionate response. Okay.
So self kindness in a way is the most
salient aspect of self compassion.
But there's also a very important element
and the self compassion that helps
differentiate it from self pity,
right?
We don't like people who
are lost in self pity Dewey.
So what's the difference between
self compassion and self pity?
There like near enemies they look kind
of similar but they're actually radically
different.
So with self compassion,
we recognize the imperfection is part of
the shared human experience that every
single person in the world isn't perfect.
I mean,
you may have a few people you really like,
you think are close,
maybe his holiness the Dalai
Lama or some author you love.
But I share even they probably
have their bad days, right?
We know no person is perfect
and no one means perfect life.
Okay,
so we know this logically,
but what happens emotionally almost
fail or we make a mistake or we feel
inadequate about something is we feel
like something has gone wrong, right?
Think about it, I failed. Something has
gone wrong. This isn't supposed to happen.
It's,
it's kind of an irrational assumption.
But in the moment we feel as if everyone
else in the world is living a perfectly
normal problem, free life.
And it's just me who's failed,
who's gotten dumped by my
boyfriend or whatever it is.
Now this is a problem because
not only are we suffering,
we feel all alone in our suffering.
So self compassion, remember,
wait, this is normal. This is
what's supposed to be happening.
No one ever said I wasn't going
to fail or experience hardship.
And I'll just tell you a little personal
story where I saw how powerful this can
be, the switch in my own life. Um, so, uh,
if you ever read the book, when you read
the book, you'll find out. And my son,
Rowan,
is artistic.
And I remember when he
was about four years old,
I have a very clear memory of taking
him to the park and there were their
mothers, their with their kids and you
know, all the other kids were playing,
laughing, interacting, you know, here's
rowing on the slide. Just stimming away,
right?
Not Interacting with the other kids.
And I started going down the path of
self pity, right? I started thinking,
you know, why me? Why can't I
have a normal happy relationship,
easy relationship with my
child like everyone else.
But I caught myself because I had been
practicing self compassion for many years
at that point. And I realize is
that Christian, wait a second,
you're assuming that all the other
mothers and kids on the playground,
you're assuming that all these mothers
are going to grow up to have perfectly
normal problem free relationships with
their kids. Are you kidding? You know,
surely they may develop other mental
health issues or physical issues or maybe
just have a very conflict
built relationship.
And I realize actually in
fact what Unitus United,
all the mothers are on the playground
that day was that we struggle with our
kids and we loved them anyway
and we do our best and this is,
this is what separated me
from the other mothers.
This is what connected me to the other.
So the second I pulled myself out of
that rabbit hole of self pity and started
giving myself self compassion, you
know, it's hard to be a parent.
It's a challenge for all of us.
Then everything got reframed and it
really gave me more emotional resources to
deal with the situation.
Okay,
so common humanity is key
and then mindfulness, right?
So as I said,
we've heard a lot about mindfulness.
I know Google's really into mindfulness.
Mindfulness is really the
foundation of self compassion.
Okay.
So mindfulness is basically being with
where it is in the present moment without
resistance. No, of course.
When what's happening in the
present moment is suffering
or going through a hard
time. We're having difficulty,
we're struggling in some way.
We actually need to have the courage
to be present with what's happening in
order to have compassion for ourselves.
And more than that,
typically what happens is when things
are difficult, we were in a process,
like I call over identification that
some were fused with the storyline of
what's happening.
We're lost in the storyline.
So in order to have compassion for
yourself and one of the reasons it's so
beneficial is you actually have to
step outside of yourself and say,
wow, you're really struggling. Are you
okay? What do you need in this moment?
And that kind of stepping outside yourself
to form a self self relationship is
one of the things that gives you emotional
balance needed to make wiser choices.
Okay? So those are the three
components, self kindness,
common humanity and mindfulness.
And actually hopefully have time.
Want to give you a little sense of what
these feel like in your body because
these are all inner concepts.
First of like give you a taste of
what self criticism feels like.
Okay? So please everyone, if
you're eating, just put it
down for a second. Uh, uh,
make two fists in front
of your body like this.
Go ahead and give him a good old squeeze
and please do not release them until I
say you can.
Okay?
It's keeping your fist like
this for a few moments.
And as you make this gesture,
just notice what I'm mood
state does this evoke in you?
What does this bring up for you?
How was your mind in this posture?
Yeah,
defensive stress.
Feel stressed.
Sorry. Tension. What'd you
think? Aggression. Right? It's
pretty uncomfortable, right?
Okay. This is what self criticism
feels like. You might even say echo,
literally beating ourselves up.
Most of the day we go around
with this attitude to ourselves.
Stress Resistant, clash,
clench, aggressive, right?
We aggressive toward herself.
Okay.
Now finally you have my permission to
open your hands and just let them raise to
the ceiling.
Okay?
So what shifts for you when you do this?
Relaxed and God
relief. What else? How
does this feel? What?
What changes in your mind
compared to before? Open.
More spacious, right? Feels lighter. Yes.
So this actually is a metaphorical
gesture for mindfulness.
What happens when we stop resisting
life and we just opened the way it is.
There's a lot of spaciousness.
A lot of room there.
Now if you put both arms
in front of you like this,
right?
Okay. So what, what comes up for
you when you make this gesture?
Sorry, what? Faith.
Warm.
Welcoming. Yeah. So in a way,
this is the gesture of common humanity.
When we give and we see, we welcome,
we embrace other people, not
just so self focused. Right?
And now if you put one hand over the
other like this and place both hands over
the center of your chest,
right? And savings.
Pause for a moment.
Really feel the warmth of your hands.
Okay.
Feel the touch of your
hands on your chest.
And so checking in, um, what
mood state does this evoke
in you? How does this feel?
See, confident. Comforting,
comforting.
Are you going to say something
kind? It feels kind, right? So this
is, um, a gesture of self kindness.
You might say this act of
being there for ourselves. Um,
but remember that self compassion isn't
just comforting and soothing and there's
another stance. It kind of represents what
we're doing. Um, and you're all sitting,
but so you can see that if you don't,
you don't have to, but you know,
the horse dance and martial arts kind of
this ground opposed your knees are bad
and you've got your
center of gravity right.
Self compassion also gives you a center
of gravity so that you can support
yourself,
remove as you needed or
even defend yourself without
being knocked off balance.
So one of the things self compassion
gives you is the ability to get through
difficult times with the
sense of balance and support.
So that's kind of what it
feels like in your body. Um,
just to say, okay. Um, you
might be thinking, okay,
sounds good,
but we have a lot of misgivings as a
culture about self compassion and when we
are raised thinking this is a good idea.
What are some of the we have as a culture
and maybe yourself or your friends
that you hear expressed.
Yes, absolutely. Yeah.
The number one actually misgiving
about self compassion is that it will
undermine your motivation. There'll
be lazy you won't, you won't.
You lose your edge. Yeah. There's,
there's lots of other misgivings
that we just heard. For sure.
It's such a good thing.
Right?
So just letting yourself off the hook.
It's an excuse
that it's a weakness.
Yeah, that's for sissies.
I remember once I have a New York Times
article came out about my work and I
really thought all the comments
would be good. I really did.
About a third of them weren't. And
I've got comments like, oh great,
just what we need a nation of Susie's
right. So people think it is for sissies.
It's weak. Yeah. Maybe like
selfish. It's selfish, right?
I already supposed to be focused
on compassion for others.
What do you mean give
compassion for myself? Right.
So there's a lot of very
common misgivings. Um, uh,
very, you know, used to be,
I would, I could give you
lots of very well argued, um,
the reasons why I think these
misgivings are misconceptions,
but actually now we have the research
to really address all these misgivings.
So just a little chart. You can see I'm
back in 2003 there. I publish a first,
um,
theoretical article on self compassion,
what it is and I quit it to skill to my
trip and now it's just exploding and we
couldn't even keep up with the research
is absolutely amazing. And so we've got,
we know a lot now about self
compassion and how it works.
So just to say first of all a self
compassionate as strongly predictive of
wellbeing. Some people who are more self
compassionate or who are helped, um,
taught to be more self compassionate
and they tend to be less depressed,
tend to be less anxious and they're less,
lot of people suffer from shame,
suicidal ideation,
um,
at the same time they're happier and
they're more optimistic right there.
They're more hopeful about their future.
So this kind of overlaps with self esteem.
We also know that self esteem is good
for wellbeing people high self esteem.
I also you know,
have better mental health.
The difference between self esteem and
self compassion is it first of all self
esteem is based on social
comparisons often, right?
You have to even better than others
to be thought of high self esteem,
self compassionate.
And you just have to be like a
wreck like every other human being.
You don't have to be better than anyone,
right? You just have to be human.
And also the sense of self worth link
with self compassion is much more stable
than self esteem.
So we did one study where
we track people's sense of
self worse for I'm 12 times
over eight months,
I'm a self esteem but went up and
down based on how your day was going,
your latest success or failure.
So if compassion was a much more
stable source of self worth,
it's there for you actually.
Precisely when self esteem desert shoot
and that's when you fall flat on your
face. Do you make a mistake or you're
struggling in some way? Um, yeah.
So it's self compassion week,
right?
What we're finding it in fact is it,
I feel comfortable
because I'm a little bias,
but I feel comfortable saying that
self compassion is probably one of the
biggest sources of strength, resilience
and coping you have available. Right?
So lots of research,
people going through divorce or when
Eddie came out of people coming back,
veterans coming back from
Iraq and Afghanistan.
And what they find is the
way people treat themselves.
And these hard times, you know, the level
of self compassion, support, inner inner,
um, beat an inner allies
and poster, an inner enemy.
That's what predicts whether or not
they do things like develop PTSD.
I'm nine months later. So self compassion
will help you get through hard times.
It's a strength. Absolutely
not a weakness. Um,
linked to healthier behaviors.
A lot of people think self compassion
means being self indulgent, you know, oh,
it'd be nice to myself.
I think they'll have that bowl of ice
cream and then another and another.
And you know, is that being
nice to yourself? Right?
It's actually not self indulgence means
choosing long term harm over short term
pleasure. People are self
compassionate. They want,
they want to levy their own suffering.
So they do things like they exercise more,
they eat better food,
they go to the doctor more regularly,
they take care of themselves.
So it's self compassion,
a selfish, um, I'll say if you
guys are pretty young crowd,
some of you are probably like on
doing the online dating thing.
I Dunno what app she got these days,
but you're probably maybe on the market,
you can actually take the self
compassion test on my website.
So I would suggest getting their
score before meeting for coffee.
Maybe not.
But regardless,
the idea is we know that people who are
more self compassionate are rated by
their partners, is being
much better. Relationship
Partners, they're more giving,
they're more intimate,
they're less controlling,
they're less aggressive in
the relationship. So in fact,
what we know is that when you
give yourself what you need,
when you have this pool of
compassion to draw on for yourself,
you actually more to give to others.
So at least the less selfish behavior,
that more selfish behavior.
And in fact we also know that people
who are more self compassionate,
not only are they more
compassionate to others,
they're more able to sustain
compassion for others, right?
So if you have this pattern where
I'm giving, I'm giving, I'm giving,
I'm giving to my friends,
I'm giving to my partner,
I'm giving to my children and you don't
recharge your own batteries and you
don't give yourself what you
need, you will burn out. So I'm,
a lot of the research I'm
doing now actually is like
teaching as self compassion
to caregivers to help
them prevent for now.
So I just want to have a
little more detail on this one.
The idea how it's linkedin
motivation cause this is the
one people just say this,
there's a lot of research on this because
I think a lot of researchers that no,
this can't be true. Surely
not. But it is, right? So, um,
we have lots of research showing,
first of all,
people who are self compassionate
and their standards are
just as high. You know,
they, they also want the best
for themselves. The differences.
What happens when a self compassionate
person does it meet their standards?
Right? So a self critical person
when they fail, beat themselves up.
Oh I'm terrible. I can't, I
should have gotten a ride.
And they like this whole slew of
self judgment and self criticism,
which does two things. A, it
undermined yourself. Confidence,
right? When you think,
oh, I'm a failure, I'm full of shame.
Shame is not exactly the most
motivating mindstate we can have.
So undermines herself competence.
And what happens is we become,
we become afraid of failure.
We developed performance anxiety and
it actually undermines her performance.
This, this process of self shame
and self criticism, self compassion.
On the other hand,
when you know it's okay to fail for spa,
you can recognize that you fail because
you know, yeah, okay. It's safety. Okay.
I own it.
It really messed up there.
But just because I failed
doesn't mean I am a failure.
So self compassionate
people are much more, uh,
much less likely to be afraid of failure.
And when they do fail,
they're much more likely, um, to try
again and to keep on trying. Okay.
So for instance, they just study at
Uc Berkeley where they had people,
they gave these students one of those
impossible tabulary tests that everyone
failed. And half the students, they
told them to be self compassionate.
They gave them self
compassion instructions. The
other half they said, hey,
don't worry about it. You must be
smart. You got into Berkeley. Right?
And then they had a second
vocabulary tests and they made it,
how long did the students
study for the second exam?
So the ones who were helped to be self
compassionate spend a lot more time
studying and they kept trying
even though you know, the, the,
the potential for failures there because
he had this resilience and the strength
to deal with it. Okay. I want to
teach you a little practice, um,
because I'm hoping that you guys can
actually some point in your day to day or
the next week,
um,
can actually put this into practice and
see how it impacts how you relate to
yourself in times of struggle because
it's more than just conceptual.
This is actually a practice.
Okay. So if someone comes in,
I think about 10 minutes, I just
kicked him out. Okay. All right.
So,
um,
I invite everyone to close your eyes
partly just because I want you to be able
to go inward and I don't want you to
feel like other people are looking at you
because I'm going to have you make
a few funny gestures. Sorry. Okay.
All right.
So with their eyes close and actually
the first thing I'd like us to do is see
if we can find a type
of supportive gesture,
physical touch that feels supportive.
And some people really like the
hands on the heart touch I used,
but actually a lot of people don't
like that. It feels vulnerable.
It doesn't really affect them.
So I want us just to see if we can find
some sort of touch that feels good for
us. So why don't we go ahead and start
again with the hands on heart like we did
before.
All right.
Just noticing how that feels.
A lot of people love this gesture.
It feels safe and comforting and soothing.
Um, but as I said, a lot
of people don't like this.
It feels weak or feels vulnerable.
So some other variations you can do is
you can try putting a fist on your heart
it fist of like strength, courage, power,
and then place the hand
gently over the fist,
right?
Some people like this,
oftentimes men like this gesture more.
Okay.
Um, you can try putting
both hands on your belly.
Okay.
Right.
Supporting your belly
and then both hands on your face.
Okay. So just take a moment to see if he
can find some touch that works for you.
Um, it's amazing if you have
a self compassionate touch,
it cuts through all the mental chatter
and you can go straight toward kind of
emotionally giving to yourself.
So just experiment a little bit or
eyes are still closed and for now,
choose something that seems
to work kind of. Okay.
Yeah.
Sound a lifelong commitment and just
try it out for now. I'm going to need,
we're going to use this in the
next exercise. Okay. So what,
why eyes are still closed and I hear
the noise. So people are coming in.
That's all right.
So what I would invite you to do
is see if you can think of, um,
a real situation in your life right now.
Yeah.
That's causing you some stress or
struggle or some emotional difficulty,
okay.
Right? This may be a
relationship issue, work issue.
I'm a health issue,
right?
Um,
don't,
don't choose your most overwhelmingly
difficult problem because we're just
practicing. We don't want to overwhelm
ourselves. There's something, this wheel,
something that's, you know, you can kind
of feel the stress of it in your body.
So taking a moment to
think of this situation,
right?
Call it into your mind eye.
You know who said what.
Okay.
Uh, what happened? What are
you afraid might happen?
Okay? So see if you can make it real.
Bring it into the present moment.
Then I can get to say a series of phrases
designed to evoke the three components
of self compassion. Um,
so the first phrase is,
this is a moment of suffering.
Okay?
Okay. This mindfulness we're being,
we're being aware of what's happening.
But that language may not be the best
for you. You can say something like,
this is really hard right now,
or I'm struggling.
Yeah.
Okay.
So we want to use our mindfulness to
just neem and become aware of the fact of
what's happening, which is
this is, this is difficult.
Okay?
Okay.
The second phrase is a
suffering or struggle.
Stress.
It's a part of life,
right? So we're just
remembering our common humanity.
This is normal to feel this way.
Things like this happen,
they hurt,
but it's normal as part of being a human.
I'm not alone in feeling this way.
Okay? And then, so for the
third component, self kindness,
I'd invite you to adopt
whatever gesture you found.
Fields kind of comfort, name,
hand on heart or elsewhere,
just on heart,
hand on stomach,
whatever seems like it gives you
that feeling of being supported,
right?
And so at the third phrase is,
may I be kind to myself?
Right?
So what does this mean? It's asking,
what do I need in this moment?
And seeing if you can kind
of wish that for yourself.
Maybe you know,
what you need is patience,
courage,
or maybe we need is to accept
yourself that little bit more,
right? Just asking yourself, what do
I need? And wishing that for yourself.
Okay.
Um, and if, and if you're getting
a little stuck with the language,
is often really useful to think,
you know,
what would I say to a close friend
who was going through the exact same
situation I'm going
through, right? We're off.
We're kind of naturally more
compassionate to our friends.
So thinking about what you would say
and also maybe the tone of voice,
you would use the warmth
that would be in your voice.
Okay.
Right. And then, then just
try it out with yourself.
See if he can speak to yourself the
same way you would speak to a friend.
You cared about the same issue.
Okay.
And then letting the practice go
for your hands back by your sides.
Um,
you can open your eyes.
Okay.
So this is called the
self compassion break.
It's one of the kind of most handy dandy
tools from the mindful self compassion
program we teach. Um, but the idea is in
the moment of struggle, not like you know,
in a separate time when you're
meditating or you can do it then too,
in the heat of the moment,
you remind yourself of the
three components of compassion,
being mindful that you're having a hard
time remembering this is part of life is
not just me,
this is,
this is part of being human and then
bringing kindness to yourself. Right.
It can often feel weird at first.
Absolutely.
It often feels very strange to speak to
yourself like you'd speak to good friend.
It feels, it can feel fake and phony
at first just to normalize that,
but eventually you start to form new
habits and it starts to feel natural to be
kind to yourself as opposed to awkward
and if you really work with this
practice, if you really
work on integrating self
compassion into your life,
what the research shows is that,
like I said,
it's been a tremendous
source of resilience, coping,
self confidence and motivation.
There's also research now showing it's
good for your physical health or immune
function.
For instance.
I was just curious about your view on
cynicism and sort of ways that that might
undermine sort of the overall
structure. Yeah, so again,
in our culture,
the that because a lot of people
think that self compassion is soft.
They kind of cynical about like, oh,
all this hearts and flowers stuff. Um,
so it is, it is a block, right?
And for some people, I mean,
I'm really comfortable, calm myself,
sweetheart, I'm mushy, I have a son.
But a lot of people aren't.
So the really important thing is to
find language that works for you.
Like do you got your back? I mean,
that can be whatever, you know,
be a wing man,
whatever you want to language it.
It doesn't have to be warm,
but absolutely, you know,
it's cynicism,
right?
Is it going to be better for you to
support yourself or to undermine yourself?
I mean, Duh. You know, it's so funny,
her culture somehow thinks
that by cutting yourself down,
that's going to help you.
Obviously it won't.
And all the research
shows it won't as well.
So if you want to do your best
and you can be as dry as you want,
you don't have to be warm
and mushy regardless.
You want to be your own support system
as opposed to pulling the rug out from
underneath yourself, which is what most
of us actually do with self criticism.
So cynicism is there and people just
have to find out for themselves as a
worker, not basically.
Yeah, absolutely. Yes.
Thanks for coming today.
Tried a
variety of different styles of meditation
past to try and calm my mind and calm
down that voice that's constantly
running and criticism and just find it
challenging to kind of break past that
and make it a pattern and a habit.
What tips do you have any in your approach
towards self compassion and working
at self compassion to take some of the
early steps or things to keep in mind
about the process?
Maybe too often I've expected I'm going
to have this instant breakthrough. Um,
how would you advise someone to
go about it and make it work?
Absolutely. So the first thing is we
can't get rid of the voice, right?
The voices there. We didn't choose
to have the voice. A lot of us,
especially depending on our
family history and you know,
we have the voice more deeply than others.
The first thing to do is recognize that
your inner critical voice is actually
trying to help you. It's not doing a great
job of it, but it's trying to help me.
Usually the inner critic is trying to
point out some danger, danger, danger,
don't do that. Don't do that. You know,
if you've done that one
problem wouldn't have happened.
So you might think of it is like a three
year old trying to help you in the only
language it knows how,
which is the language of self criticism.
So when you recognize you can
even just try saying like,
thank you. Um, I hear you.
Okay, I see what you're trying to
point out. Um, but then the, the,
the only problem with that self critical
voices that it's counterproductive
because by using the harsh language and
the harsh tone and it actually doesn't
help you. So I, you know,
acknowledging the inner critic
and then just saying this,
that or another part of me that
also usually wants the same goal.
I believe that we all have an inner
compassionate self and it's not just the
spiritual thing. We know like you know,
evolutionarily that we all are the brain,
the human brain is wired for compassion,
is part of our biological makeup.
So we can tap into that part of herself,
which is usually a little wiser.
And also think, you know,
what does this part of myself,
the part of me that knows how
to be supportive, good friend,
what does this have to say
about whatever's going on?
So don't try to fight the self critic.
Really see if you can turn toward it,
appreciate it for how it
was trying to help you. Then
just don't let it, you know,
be the only voice in your head. Hopefully
it can have a little more room to,
to, to lead in some other
voices. Yeah. So it really,
it really is our friend.
It's just what I think of it as like
a tangent mean two year old, you know,
it's a low on also on.
The other good thing is just to tune
in to the pain of self criticism.
You know, it hurts, ah,
the term tenderness toward this very
human process of self criticism as well.
And please do not beat yourself
up for beating yourself up. I've,
I've gotten emails from people
said, thanks for, you know,
give me one more thing done bad at self
compassion. You know, I was like, oh,
that's not what I meant.
Right?
So we want to be kind about the process
and it's slow and if you have a family
history with this is what you were
raised with, it will, it will go slower.
Just allow yourself to be a slow learner
and be patient and being patient and
understanding with the self critic
that actually is self compassionate.
In your last response, you
actually mentioned, um,
this young child's mentality and that was,
that could lead into my question is do
you have some suggestions for teaching
self compassion to young kids? Yeah. Um,
so I'm for that. I think that the
number one best way to do it of course,
is to model it.
You know,
a lot of parents are so good about not
harshly criticizing the kids and trying
to be supportive and then they dropped
the glass on the floor and say, Oh,
I'm such an idiot. You know?
So really being conscious
of what you're modeling, I,
I really believe that if you, uh, hourly
model, self compassion and moments,
a mistake or something, kids
will pick up on that message. Um,
the other cool thing is that all human
beings are brains are wired for emotional
resonance. We pick up on what other
people are feeling. So believe it or not,
if you are really self critical,
rounder kids,
you kids will notice the self
criticism and respond to it.
I'll just give an example. If my son
were all in, right? So when he was, he's,
he's doing great now,
but when he was younger,
he would have this
horrible autism tantrums.
Like just really off the charts.
And if I,
you know, and sometimes he didn't when I
got you rotated. Oh my God, you're right.
I must, I blown it. Or I triggered
him. I didn't know what to do.
And they got really frustrated
with myself. He would ramp up.
It's like he would read my emotions.
So what I learned to do when he would
throw an all muddy tantrum is I would just
flood myself with compassion. This
is so hard right now. You know,
I'm here for you and
make sure he was safe.
But like 95% of my attention
was on me and never audibly,
he would pick up on that and he would
start to calm down because he would read
my mind state. So as a parent, you
know, that relationship is so close.
If you embody another term for it,
use for self.
Compassion is loving,
connected presence, kindness,
common humanity, mindfulness,
loving, connected presence.
So if you just sync when
you're around your kid,
how can I embody a state of
loving connected presence
that we'll do a few things.
First of all,
they'll feel your loving,
connected presence will also mean your
parenting is that much more balanced and
wise, et cetera. So, um, that's
kind of step one and you know,
there probably are techniques to develop,
but I haven't done that yet.
That's what, that's,
that's, that's what I do.
Hi there.
Thank you so much for coming.
I'm so glad that you asked that question
because my question is on the same
lines of [inaudible] for kids.
So I actually work in education,
I focused on educators. So I'm curious,
you know, what, what research you have or,
or as an academic,
what you guys have done as far as helping
support educators implement compassion
and also,
so that's the first part.
And then the second part is how can we
as educators are individuals that are
really helping these individuals,
um,
help with cyber bullying and
the implementation of self
compassion for kids that
are being bullied online.
Right? So there's a lot there. Um, so
in terms of what we have for teenagers,
so we've developed,
my,
my colleague Chris Cromer and
I have developed something
called the mindful self
compassion program.
If you're interested,
you can go to center for msc.org we've
developed a teen version of that that we
can teach the teens. Um, right
now like, like in spring,
I'm the local Austin School district asked
me to come in and help their teachers
learn self compassion to present burnout.
Not a lot of research yet it's coming.
Um,
and one of my dissertation
students actually is doing
this dissertation on cyber
bullying. The idea being that
if you can help people, victims,
he was more focused on victims,
help people and be more self compassionate
when they're bullied instead of
retaliating with more bullying,
which is the normal pattern,
the actual deescalate the conflict.
So we're, we're working on it. Yeah.
But we aren't quite there yet.
Yeah. To go back to self
compassion. Yes. Uh,
I often when I feel hurt by somebody,
feel compassion for them thinking,
oh,
they must be going through hard time.
Is it okay to mix these two self
compassion and compassion for others?
Or it should be only us.
When we concentrate.
You can definitely, ideally the
idea is that it's this easy flow.
Compassion for me.
I really feel her compassion for you.
You must have stuff going on.
We actually teach you a practice called
breathing compassion in and out. Um,
so you do maintain both.
Um,
but if you only have space for one in
your [inaudible] only have enough working
memory pits for one person.
I would suggest starting
with yourself because again,
when you build the resources for yourself,
then you can have more to give to
the other and more importantly,
this sustain giving to the other.
But it doesn't have to be
either or by any means. I mean,
common humanity's common humanity.
You're a human. I'm a human.
This hurts you hurt.
You know,
ideally that's where we're
focused is just having compassion.
Typically what we do is we cut ourselves
out of the circle of compassion.
We treat ourselves
radically different lead,
then we treat others and that's a problem.
We want to create ourselves the same way,
at the same kindness and care.
Thank you so much for being here
and thank you all for being here.
Russia,
oh,
I've got the self compassion break
and other meditations and exercises.
I'm a website.
Just Google self combat.